6 24 on your monday morning got a heads
up for one of the busier surfer streets
down in henderson you know how freeway
projects are grabbing all the headlines
like the big squeeze on the 95 515 or
the spaghetti bowl but we know there are
cones lurking in all corners of the
valley well the city of henderson says
that today
tomorrow and wednesday got a repaving
project and stephanie is going to be
down to one lane in each direction
starting at six which was just a few
minutes ago running until four in the
afternoon again today tomorrow and on
wednesday from the 215 up to the reunion
pacific railroad tracks just south of
american pacific now work like this
usually happens during overnight hours
but henderson says temperature
requirements for las vegas pavings
asphalt are making it a daytime project
now during the work hours getting to or
from the 215 might be easier if you go
over to valley verde to the west or
gibson to the east buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
something's driving you crazy email me
traffic eight at eight news now dot com